if we say you know the body's attacking  itself or  you know an allergy is like a  misunderstanding of like  you know something benign or whatever we  still kind of get this  relationship uh being born you know to  the body that says oh  silly body you're messing up again right  and if you can get to a place where you  understand  that without understanding the details  the body's  wisdom far surpasses your conscious  awareness  and that the invitation is to develop  that conscious awareness to learn  and you will it will become clear right  to you  what your body is trying to tell you  which again can range from the psycho  spiritual to  the very gross physical right so like  you're b12 deficient oh you know um  all the way to the fact that you know  you  you really need to start talking about  your childhood sexual abuse you're gonna  know  you know what this is about and often  it's multi-layered